اقتحمت قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي مصحوبه
بجرافات عسكريه المنطقه الشرقيه من مدينه
نابلس بالضفه الغربيه وداهمت مخيم عسكر
الجديد شرقي المدينه وسط اطلاق نار من قبل
مقاومين نحو اليات وجنود الاحتلال وافادت
مصادر محليه ان قوات الاحتلال تحاصر
المخيم وتنشر فرق القناصه في عده مواقع
مطله على
المخيم معنا من رام الله مراسل الجزيره
حسام مسعود
نجمل التطورات المتعلقه بالاقتحام سواء في
طولكرم او في
نابلس ونبدا ايضا من اخر التطورات من هنا
من محافظه رام الله والبيره وتحديدا من
مخيم قلنديا الواقع شمال القدس وعند مدخل
محافظه رام الله والبيره حيث اقتحمت قبل
قليل فقط قوات الاحتلال اكثر من ثمان
اليات عسكريه اقتحمت المخيم واقتحامات
مخيم قلنديا عاده ما تشهد حمله واسعه من
قبل قوات الاحتلال تشمل مداهمات وكذلك
يمكن ان تتطور الى مواجهات بين الشبان
وقوات الاحتلال هذا التطور ياتي في سياق
حمله واسعه من الاقتحامات نفذتها قوات
الاحتلال خلال هذه الليله من شمال الضفه
الغربيه
وتحديدا في كل من محافظات طولكرم ونابلس
وكذلك محافظه جنين من جنين تحديدا قامت
قوات الاحتلال باقتحام بلده جبع الواقعه
جنوب جنين كما قامت كذلك
باقتحام محافظه نابلس من الجهه الغربيه ثم
قامت باقتحام مدينه نابلس ايضا من الجهه
الشرقيه وا حتى هذه اللحظه ما زالت
المعلومات تشير الى ان مخيم عسكر الجديد
يشهد مواجهات واشتباكات بين مقاومين
فلسطينيين وقوات الاحتلال في هذا الاقتحام
الذي تنفذه خلال هذه الليله هذا ياتي ايضا
بالتزامن مع قيام قوات الاحتلال باقتحام
بلده قفين الواقعه شمال محافظه طولكرم
فيما ايضا قامت قوات الاحتلال
باقتحام ايضا مدينه قلقيليه شمالا ايضا
هنا ايضا في محافظه رام الله والبيره كان
هناك حوادث لافته من قبل مستوطنين بدايه
قام مجموعه من المستوطنين
باقتحام بلده سنجل الواقعه شمال رام الله
فيما ايضا قام مجموعه من المستوطنين
بالاعتداء على منزل احد الشهداء هنا ايضا
في محافظه رام الله والبيره وهو ايضا ياتي
في اطار هذه الحملات من الاعتداءات التي
ينفذها مستوطنون سواء عبر مجموعات او حتى
عبر افراد في عدد من المدن الفلسطينيه في
الضفه الغربيه وا في المناطق القريبه من
اماكن وجود المستوطنات غير الشرعيه في
الضفه الغربيه وهي وتيره باتت متسارعه
وتزداد بشكل يومي بشكل خاص ايضا منذ
السابع من اكتوبر وحتى اليوم ايضا قوات
الاحتلال قامت باقتحام بلده بيت فجار كذلك
في محافظه بيت لحم فيما ايضا تقوم بشكل
متواصل بتنفيذ حملات مداهمه في محافظه
الخليل هذه الاقتحامات المتواصله ادت الى
اعتقال او تسجيل
636 حاله اعتقال منذ السابع من اكتوبر
وحتى اليوم فقط فيما وصل مجموع الشهداء في
الضفه الغربيه نتيجه
لعمليات العمليات العسكريه التي ينفذ جيش
الاحتلال وعمليات الاغتيال التي ايضا يقوم
بها وكذلك اعتداءات المستوطنين الى
381 شهيدا منذ السابع من اكتوبر حسن مسعود
من رام الله شكرا جزيلا
لك